welcome to the Michaela Peterson podcast
this is episode for this episode I speak
with Hamilton Morris Hamilton Morris is
an American journalist and
pharmacological researcher he's known
for his television series Hamilton's
from a capilla where he investigates the
chemistry history and cultural impact of
various psychoactive drugs
Hamilton's super cool in the last eight
months or so I've been messaging him a
bit about nootropics and some other
drugs just to learn more before I was
into the carnivore diet I tried all the
neutral books I could as well as some
heavier drugs to solve my health
problems that were literally destroying
my life that was before I knew that diet
could have such a major impact on health
when I was more used to popping pills to
fix my problems that was 2012 to 2014
then I switched over to dye in
supplements in 2015-2016 then I dropped
all the supplements then I got to the
lion diet until late 2019 when I started
experimenting with supplements again now
that I'm healthier I can actually
tolerate a few supplements finally I
don't recommend them generally unless
you need them but I've been under a ton
of stress and find some useful more
excitingly though I've seen the healing
properties of psychedelics it's
something I'm fascinated by him Hamilton
has been my go-to guy to discuss
anything related to ingesting chemicals
or plans for that matter so let's get
started
[Music]
hey Hamilton Morris welcome to my
podcast I'm really excited to have you
on thanks for thanks for agreeing no
problem did you start doing this during
the pandemic yeah I figured everyone's
stuck at home and everyone's listening
to podcasts so okay well I know a bit
about you
I watched your Joe Rogan episode one of
your Joe Rogan episodes I know you've
been on there a few times and I knew
about Hamilton's pharmacopoeia I feel
like I knew about that a long time ago
like when it first started so I've seen
some of those episodes but I thought for
people who didn't know who you were you
could give a bit of a background of who
you are and I'm interested in knowing
like how you got started researching
drugs yeah so I've been making a sort of
documentary series it has had various
incarnations for the last 12 to 13 years
and it's been different things at
different times at the beginning it was
done on an incredibly low budget and it
was at a time when doing that sort of
video documentary work was substantially
less popular so it was actually when I
started out it was a sort of video
companion to a written piece that would
appear in a magazine and that kind of
the big piece of content from these
trips was actually a written article not
a video but that changed very quickly
and the emphasis is placed on video work
and then it transitioned from something
that was done primarily for YouTube to
an actual television show and I've done
a lot of reporting on psychoactive drugs
for various other networks outside
advice you know I worked for National
Geographic for a period had done through
more news oriented stuff I guess this
was revised on their HBO show and and
yeah but my interest is always
pharmacology chemistry and psychoactive
drugs in the kind of sociological
elements surrounding those topics okay
interesting I didn't realize there was
more written work to begin with I'm fun
to look into
I was actually never interested in the
video stuff at the beginning that's
correct it came much later that was
always kind of I thought that the
writings was the way to do it but yeah a
lot of people learn better I guess
visually I definitely learned better
reading and can skim through a lot of
information a lot faster than I can
listen to it I guess but apparently
people like watching things yeah okay so
I think what I'm gonna do is kind of go
through a list of questions cuz I have a
whole bunch of them and I asked kind of
my audience on Instagram what they were
interested in and there were a lot of
repetitive questions so I'm gonna get
into that but some of the questions I
had well how old were you when you
started experimenting because you don't
just do research right you actually
experiment with a lot of these drugs so
how old were you when you started doing
that um depends on how you define
experimenting you know if I you know
smoked pot a little bit in middle school
and used salvia when I was in high
school but I didn't become very
interested in psychedelics and begins
through methodically investigating them
until I was in college and then it
wasn't until even after that that I
started you know having the opportunity
to work in a lab and to actually you
know do real experiments because I know
that there's a look at kind of this like
euphemistic winking aspect of like oh
it's an experiment haha but you're
really you know using a drug and that's
like you know I guess because drugs make
people feel good there's an idea that
you couldn't legitimately be
experimenting with them in some way but
but anyway so yeah so there was a period
of just you know using drugs out of
personal interest when I was much
younger and then that developed into a
kind of obsession where I tested a lot
of different things in various ways
okay when you first started doing that
did you do things like you know as
scientifically as you could one at a
time and then writing down your whole
experiments and then you know combining
them just seeing the effects that way or
what does it look like yeah yeah that
was that was a big part of it was you
know trying to just do these basic
things that really anyone can do to to
try to extract a little bit more useful
information out of your own self
experiments so you know namely doing
whatever you can to identify the
compound in question if you have access
to analytical instruments in a lab
that's really ideal so that you can you
know have you there GCMs or NMR data
that you know actually identified the
substance in question but you know
whatever you might have access to doing
your best to understand that you
actually have that material and you
don't weighing it out on a sensitive
scale and taking notes and things like
that just to get a better understanding
of these things to try to develop a a
you know you never become immune to the
placebo effects but you can and that's
really the nature of the placebo effect
is that if you think you can resist it
you don't understand it but but what you
can do is you can sort of you know learn
to think logically about pharmacological
responses to drugs and sort out what
makes sense and what doesn't make sense
and begin to maybe make slightly more
informed assessments of various things
yeah okay that makes sense um I did a
lot of experimentation well my thing is
mainly diet and I've had like just wild
experiences just with cutting foods out
and putting them back in so I've done
some testing out I haven't done testing
out on drugs like you have but when I
was first like quite ill with an
autoimmune disorder I was taking you
know hoards of medications trying to
make myself better and one of the things
I kind of looked into where Neotropics
because I was taking a high dose of
adderall and that was the only thing
that was keeping me awake
and I was looking for other ways to stay
awake because I was growing a tolerance
to the adderall like continually so I
was wondering if you have drugs you use
more frequently or daily that help with
cognitive function or anything that you
find valuable you know there was a time
when I was very very interested in
nootropics because when I was a freshman
in college I was at a prescription for
adderall and the really one year of
using it and not you know using it at
the prescribed dose which was pretty low
I think was taking something like 20
milligrams a day really had dramatically
negative effects on my emotional and
physical health like I lost a lot of
weight and it was clear to me that it
wasn't sustainable that I couldn't
continue taking amphetamine as a
treatment for ADHD regardless of how
effective it may have been and then
there's another question I think that's
really crucial with that which is the
difference between something feeling
effective and being definitely with
adderall okay I was taking 40 to 50 and
it was mainly to stay awake but I did
two years basically six days a week and
then I'd take Sundays off um and sleep
and eat because it kills your appetite
but it was it was really hard on my
short-term memory hmm that's interesting
yeah what happened with you with the
year of use other than the weight loss
wasn't it wasn't abuse I mean it really
was just prescribed used that's that's
the wild thing it was I would say that
it's very tricky because it gives you
this enthusiastic interest in everything
that you're doing and it makes obviously
studying extremely enjoyable it makes
investigating tangents and whatever
you're working on extremely fulfilling
and enjoyable and it's easy to mistake
the drama of your experience with a
therapeutic effect or to confuse it with
a therapeutic effect in somewhat and
and I was looking for something that I
could use that would allow me to
experience some version of that more
sustainably sir than when I was a
sophomore in college I started you know
testing at that time pretty much every
new trophic supplement that was on the
market on myself and I tried you know
the half dozen or so raised him
compounds that were being sold and new
pepped and various choline supplements
and ashwagandha Hyder G and this was a
bit before the lion's mane craze but
really you know I would say at minimum
maybe 20 different things and I was very
interested in them and many of them are
active in some way they do something but
whether they do something useful is
another question you'd be create a sense
of something happening but then then it
turns into a bigger question of what are
you even looking for
what is it is the you know you want it a
euphoric stimulant Kaushal none of those
drugs or very few of them are
dopaminergic and are going to have that
type of amphetamine effect you really
don't find many things that will do
something like that in a sustainable way
unfortunately so then what are you
looking for improved memory is that is
that really the problem because there's
a lot of non pharmacological ways to
improve your ability to remember things
and in fact I would say that those are
much better pads to travel than
attempting to you know snort you know
antidiuretic hormone or something like
that which will improve your memory but
also have other weird side effects and
it's probably not mainly the inability
to urinate but it will you know help
these these like you know it's not a
sustainable path again so then then is
it about focus is it about somehow
increasing some more abstract components
of your cognition like creativity
language it really depends on what
someone is looking for
so I tested all of them I was sort of
interested in what they did I felt the
whole thing was inconclusive ultimately
and I emerge from it somewhat skeptical
of the entire idea not to say that it's
impossible I don't think that it is I'm
sure there there are compounds that
improve memory it seemed to have a sort
of performance enhancing effect for
certain types of intellectual tasks but
but there's nothing that I take every
day and say this is it you know it's all
about taking modafinil every day or it's
all about taking a lion's mane
supplements every day and that will
solve these problems I don't think there
is any single compound but I think that
you know a lot of a lot of this is about
you know through self experimentation
you can begin to figure out what works
for you and what makes sense and what's
sustainable and what's healthy and so it
wasn't a waste of time or even money for
that matter I I'm glad that I played
around with all those things but as a
dancer that question now how do I take
anything no I you know I I I drink tea I
used to use a lot of nicotine gum
but it's nicotine is so insanely
addictive that there's no way at least
for me to use it a little bit
responsibly that's interesting yeah like
I think that that would be a pretty good
one for a lot of things like I love to
shoot nicotine gum and read a book
it's like one of my just and just spend
a whole day just like you know I think
it complements a lot of intellectual
tasks very well like amphetamine but
it's just so easy to get to a place
where you never stop using it yeah
that's not ideal I'm that I kind of
segues into another question I had is
through your experimentation have you
ever formed any dependencies that you
had to get rid of yeah yeah
for the most part I've been pretty
careful but when I was much younger I I
was dependent on prescribed
benzodiazepines that wasn't fun yeah and
I that's that's the big one I would say
that was the only the only time that
I've had
experience of being no truly physically
dependent on a substance and having a
kind of long-lasting disruptive
discontinuation syndrome that was really
miserable you know obviously if you're
prescribed amphetamine or ritalin you're
a little off for a while afterwards but
that's different then it's it's
different yeah okay yeah well we've
talked a little bit my dad's
experiencing pencil withdrawal currently
and he's having just an absolutely
miserable time and it was just a
prescribed medication that you know
don't take that every day because you
can form a dependency to it but
unfortunately we weren't aware the only
thing I've kind of experienced was I was
on prescribed to oxycontin for a year
really high dose and I had a pretty I
got off of it fine but it was pretty
miserable for quite a while after that
but nothing like what I've seen benzo
with benzos do unfortunately okay that
things are insidious they really yeah
they seem somewhat transparent and they
seem like something that isn't a big
deal
but yeah obviously it can be for a lot
of people too I looked at some of the
statistics and it's like 80% of people I
don't know if this is true but 80% of
people prescribed that don't get off of
it which is like that's bad that's
that's rough
yeah I think one reason that happens is
because the you know the generalized
anxiety disorder diagnosis gives people
the sense that there's something wrong
with them and so they need to take it as
a family medication in the same way that
you know a diabetic might have to take
insulin when yeah and then I hear that
all the time from you know friends
people I know that become dependent on
xanax or whatever is they'll say you
know oh you don't understand I have
really serious anxiety and I need it for
that whole at that point once you're
dependent on it the the sense that you
have really serious things ideas are
true because if you stop using it you
will have very anxiety far worse than
you did before starting I mean there's a
real kind of unfortunate irony in
pharmacology where it's often the case
that whatever drug you're taking you
will end up with a more severe version
of whatever effect you are trying to
avoid by taking that drug so you take
stimulants because you're tired and
unfocused and eventually you become more
tired and more in focus and you work
before the stimulants you take it as it
means because you have insomnia anxiety
of having worse insomnia and worse
anxiety you take opioids for pain you
end up having worst pain so it's a treat
happens do you think that happens with
SSRIs as well you end up with worse
depression as a result of the SSR and
just does it do you think it gives like
when we went to Russia with my dad I
spoke with some doctors and they thought
that like they told me that they could
see brain changes from SSRI use for so
long which isn't something that's talked
about here at all and I was wondering
when I stopped taking SSRIs because I
took them from like 12 to 23 and a high
dose
I was pretty crazy for like two years
and I got that under control with diet
but I'm
not sure how much of that was actually
damaged from taking so many medications
it's hard to say yeah I mean there are
changes but they're often framed as
being positive one so you know the main
the main one that's talked about is an
increase in hippocampal volume after
therapeutic use of SSRIs just thought to
be associated with the antidepressant
effect so but then it'll also be you
know tolerance associated changes with
the serotonin transporter and and then
you know a lot of those changes manifest
when you discontinue the drug so that's
when you end up with you know things
like brain zaps or the sort of emotional
instability or all those other problems
that are associated with SSRI
discontinuation I was lucky I was really
lucky like I got off of oxycontin when I
was 17 and I felt like absolute crap for
six weeks and then I had two years of
feeling kind of iffy but it wasn't that
bad I stopped like heavy use of SSRIs I
just stopped and nothing really happened
same with adderall like as soon as my
fatigue went away from diet changes I
just stopped and I didn't have any
withdrawal or anything so and I've heard
some people have bad withdrawal from
SSRIs well not bad like benzos but like
brain zaps and things and I was super
lucky I didn't get any of that that was
nice yeah okay then these are these are
questions that a whole bunch of people
wanted to know about I mean you do a lot
of work with or have done a lot of work
with psychedelics which so so here are
some questions for that what's your fave
do you have a favorite no no not any but
there are differences I haven't tried
that many so there are in terms of my oh
yeah yeah no no huh do you have a least
favorite um least favorite no I don't
think so I don't I mean I it depends
again it's like it's like the nootropic
issue with all these things doesn't what
you're looking for what the point of it
is or what you're trying to do because
psychedelics are so different especially
if you're talking you know and they're
in a really broad sense where you
include you know non serotonergic on
classical psychedelics but no I don't I
definitely don't have a favorite because
I think they're all so different and
some of them you know have can be used
more socially some of them are less
social some of them you know emphasize
your personality and your environment
some of them are sort of dissociative
type experiences where you become
completely detached from your own
personality and memory and experiences
and environment all like that which ones
are like that well at least among
classical psychedelics five Meo DMT
would be I think a important example
where it's it's a you know the
psychedelics bind to a variety of
different serotonin receptors but the
two main ones that are discussed in
scientific literature are v h t 2a and v
h d 1a and it seems this is like a kind
of preliminary it seems that the
psychedelics that exert the majority of
their activity via v h t1 a often have a
more kind of dissociative component
where a lot of a typical responses
instead of pupil dilation some people's
pupils are constricted instead of
becoming you know aware of your
environment enhanced communication you
can actually lose consciousness you
become unresponsive they in my
experience instead of you know with that
something like DMT or ayahuasca there's
a kind of I think like a very ego
oriented
focus on my memories my experiences my
family my friends my teachers all the
the what immediately surrounds me
everything having to do with my life and
it's very very personal
whereas with something like five amiyo
DMT it's very impersonal my experience
seems as if it could be interchangeable
with anybody's experience it's not about
my life life in general so that's like a
super oversimplified version of these
two types of psychedelics that fall
under the umbrella of a classical
serotonergic psychedelic and and they're
used in very different ways you know one
one something you can take a a medium or
a low dose of LSD and you can go for a
walk with your friends in the park and
have great conversations you can't do
that with something like five mio DMT
which is not a social experience and
it's it's one that is entirely internal
interesting okay I've heard and I don't
know if this is true so what's your
opinion on it I've heard that really
large doses of shrooms are similar to
ayahuasca experiences or I guess five
Meo DMT experiences is that true I think
yes yeah that's true I mean I think that
you know there's a really substantial
structural overlap between solisten and
psilocybin and DMT sillas in which is
the active metabolite of psilocybin is
four hydroxy DMT and that oxygen
primarily seems to confer resistance to
the enzyme Mao but it also exerts some
pharmacological changes as well so I
won't say it's that quite that simple
but you know at the the experience of a
high dose sillas n' and the experience
of a high dose of DMT are are quite
similar but again you can do things with
DMT that you can't really do with Scylla
sanur psilocybin where you know most
let's say responsible or somewhat
reasonable people wouldn't want to take
insanely insanely high dose of
psilocybin and people will maybe like
about that but I was an insanely high
dose of psilocybin let's say 15
milligrams okay what does that in like
grams of shrooms um maybe like a quarter
a quarter ounce something like that
that's a little it's quite a bit yeah
and yeah most people wouldn't want to do
that why because it's not really
necessary to do that you know you can
you can get almost everything you would
want to get or need to get from a dose
that much again people will disagree
with me on this we'll say it's
completely different much higher doses
that's fine I know plenty of people that
for whatever reason seem to have gotten
a lot of benefit from taking these
extremely high doses for the majority of
people it's totally unnecessary but
something like DMT is really interesting
because it allows you to have that type
of experience that someone might have at
a very very high dose of mushrooms but
to explore it in a slightly more
controlled manner because the duration
is so short that you don't have to worry
about it how am I gonna navigate this
for the next four or five hours so it's
like you know that's a yeah I don't I
had a wild experience I did um I did
eight grams of mushrooms and had a
pretty intense experience that was quite
different from the usual like three and
a half grams that I took it was wild it
was great it was amazing it was
transformative but I haven't I haven't
dealt a lot into other ones so I'm
looking to try out ayahuasca at one
point if I can stop this all meat diet
eventually why do you think you over his
traditional prescriptions against the
consumption of meat before the ceremony
what is the no no I'm just I'm on an
all-beef diet for autoimmune disorders
literally I've just been eating beef for
years and plants seem to give me she
seems to make me crazy
oh I'm literally just worried about the
plant liquid like that's it as well
which are TIA formal
where you use synthetic that's what I
want when I go to do that I don't think
there's anywhere to go to do it
unfortunately there's no like you could
you know there are certainly ways to
we're wasted okay I'll do it
and yeah it's I think that's definitely
the way that I do it not because of a
dietary problem in plans but because so
is that just DMT and an MAOI yeah okay
that seems like it would invoke less of
an autoimmune response than drinking
ayahuasca yeah and I think there's a lot
of advantages to doing it that way and
again people will debate this endlessly
but I because I mean there's there's may
be reasons that using plants have a
benefit even within a kind of
materialist scientific framework but
anyway there are I think major
advantages to using isolated chemicals
and main one is being able to control
the dosage of the material that you're
consuming and because when you drink the
ayahuasca vayan on the maoi compounds in
that buying harmine and harmaline and
tetrahydroharmine
they're not just maoi is they have their
own psychedelic activity without any DMT
at all so they're they're very potent
psychoactive compounds that have a
really interesting history they were
used experimental extremis for
Parkinson's disease they've been used to
have you've been used for quite a few
things so they're not just simple Mao is
they have a real complex pharmacology
and but I don't like them I don't like
the feeling that they produce it's it's
a very sedating it's incredibly
nauseating like is that part of the
reason why a lot of people get sick for
Moscow you think yes it's definitely
part of them that's not that's not great
although they say that that's purging
right so that's therapeutic sounds not
great though
yeah I mean it's it's nice that people
have worked out a framework to make
things like vomiting positive and I
appreciate that and maybe you know you
may be under some circumstances it is
but I would imagine it's I think it's
better to avoid it
it seems like it's better so so but even
that's controversial everything is you
know everything is controversial but and
nothing's very distracting you know it's
a it's like and you could say that like
so many painful things if there's some
benefit to be derived from it like you
know it's also painful to take a cold
shower but a lot of people myself
included do it because it wakes you up
and has this kind of a certain tonic
effect that's maybe worth worth while so
I get it there is something you know
like it's not always good to avoid
suffering at all costs in fact it's
often there's often some benefit in
suffering and and and in my experiences
with a lot of indigenous groups that
I've been fortunate enough to spend time
with while working on my TV show is that
there's a tremendous amount of
discomfort introduced into these
experiences discomfort is a huge part of
the experience it's not about comfort
you know when when people in the United
States take a psychedelic you do it with
your friends you do it in a comfortable
place you get a lot of food you don't
you know you don't really do anything
that is unpleasant I was in West Africa
a couple times this winter and what
really struck me was you know how
aggressive and painful the iboga
ceremonies were for people I mean really
really something I would say so
extreme that it could it would never
even be considered viable or permissible
in the United States as a serving on the
United States in any kind of medical
framework but really even within like a
kind of New Age community it would be
considered totally unacceptable and then
because it involves so much fasting such
extreme fasting such extreme exertion
all of this stuff but but you know the
people that I met that did this really
felt that they had benefited from it and
my own slightly less extreme
participation those ceremonies which did
involve fasting was amazing but really
really did you how long did you fast for
not very long
all in a day would you play what do they
do
a week I've done that I did that the
last time I did a week long fast I took
a bunch of hallucinogens I can't I mean
you didn't eat any
I was just saltwater it's just all
around yeah yeah it was it was cool I'm
pretty I got used to fasting though so
it wasn't the first time I fasted hmm it
was really it was really good it was
like a clean cleaner feeling there's
definitely less um like nausea and stuff
that sounds intense though I was
certainly not in West Africa I was like
on a couch we tired during know the
longer you fast if you do these extended
fasts your adrenaline kicks up like
majorly kicks up the longer you don't
eat like and that's to encourage you to
like go find something to eat go hunt or
whatever but your Drennen kicks up so
you're pretty wired by like day five
that's interesting yet it to me it's
fine it's fun you should try it if you
if you drink enough salt water like if
you just keep drinking the salt water
you can get used to it and train your
body and you get some pretty interesting
cognitive like highs after you know 36
hours really it doesn't take that long
but um the clarity of mind is amazing
your sense of smell gets better your
eyesight gets better it's really cool
mmm you're gonna focus I get a little
bit more volatile it's good I get calmer
if I have to go into a stressful
environment and I don't eat for 36 hours
before I have some sort of stressful
meeting it doesn't stress me out as much
but I also have less compassion and less
patience for people it's interesting hmm
yeah it's one there's so many things
that you feel you need like you know it
feels like a small emergency if you're
thirsty and don't have access to water
or if you need to key and can't pee and
then but once the possibility of getting
water or peeing is taken away you
quickly adapt and can usually just live
for quite a bit longer than you thought
you could and that was how I felt about
this this ceremony where it was 24 hours
without sleep or food bands that's
intense the sleeping part - yeah that's
I'm more used to the fasting but not
sleeping that sounds like it would be
hard that sounds like it would be hard
but this also involves the consumption
of a large amount of this plant iboga
that gives you sort of not just an
energy but also a like global anti
craving effect that that is usually only
considered in the context of opioid
addiction but I think extends well
beyond that into all all cravings you've
become just immensely peaceful and non
desiring of all things even sleep or
food or water you can kind of make peace
with exactly what you have and occupy
this mind state where it feels like you
know you're just we realize our not
dying and everything else can wait and
it's okay so that that was something
that was uncomfortable it was very
beneficial so anyway I guess this is all
about ayahuasca formal osku and whether
there are plant free alternatives and I
would say that yes the you know these
the the farm Alaska is is substantially
less uncomfortable there's no vomiting
there's no nausea and and the experience
has a more energy and clarity because it
doesn't have the sedating component that
the beta-carboline alkaloids contribute
so from a certain perspective my
perspective it's really fantastic but
you don't have any of the suffering that
may or may not be beneficial depending
on how you think about these things
you're such a handy person to know okay
okay I've got more questions so you
don't have a favorite hallucinogen okay
do you have a favorite so you weren't a
fan of amphetamines you said well I'm
certainly a fan I think that they're you
know really amazing compounds if
anything they're too good
it's really their law is that they they
need to be toned down a little bit so
way to tone them down too because I like
like I was prescribed at all like I said
for fatigue major fatigue and I'm not
sure if I liked it I think my dose was
too high it made me kind of
uncomfortable but I definitely see the
utility and using it occasionally if it
didn't completely destroy your appetite
and things like that is there a way to
use those effectively just lower dose
for different types or what yeah I mean
for some some people are able to use
them very occasionally that's one way I
mean I think that like within the kind
of dopaminergic stimulate certain
hedonic spectrum and on one ends
actually caffeine is not dopaminergic as
a different mechanism but on one end you
have stimulants like caffeine that are
almost entirely non euphoric maybe if
you're totally if you never use caffeine
in a cup of tea or something would be
very good for it but for someone who
drinks coffee or tea every day it's not
especially euphoric you haven't maybe
feel good in the morning but it's not
like you don't won't fundamentally
change your behavior where you'll be you
know writing to people you don't
normally talk to or doing things that
are unusual and then you know one step
beyond that you have Ritalin ritalin
which is is euphoric but not powerful
euphoric and is you know a little bit
more than than caffeine but certainly
less than something like I'm feta mean
where where you do have a certain like
hypomanic a factory the havior has
changed and and you start to envy and
you also have like an emotional
instability that's associated as well I
can come down things like that and then
you have things like you know provigil /
modafinil that that fall somewhere in
between caffeine and Ritalin probably
also largely non euphoric but with maybe
that the small euphoric effect so yeah I
think that like that that's been a big a
big problem really in in
design has been how to treat a lot of
disorders without drugs that are too
good you know it's like we have all
these treatments for anxiety but they're
almost too effective they instead of
subtly modulating the way that you
respond to life events that might cause
anxiety they like completely blunt it
cause you forea cause dependence cause
all these problems it's this same issue
with the treatment of insomnia which is
you know in terms of pharmacology the
pharmacology a lot of with insomnia
treatments and anxiety treatments are
very similar and it's that's been the
big issue with insomnia and with ADHD
and with so many of these things is not
that we can't find good treatments or a
million good treatments it just happens
to be the case that they often are
incredibly euphoric and addictive and so
how do you exert that therapeutic effect
without enslaving people
pharmacologically yeah and the
pharmaceutical companies have tried I
mean that's it that's another kind of
pharmacological irony is people will get
angry at pharmaceutical companies for
producing all these addictive drugs well
they often produce non-addictive ones
but then people don't like them because
they're non euphoric like you know
there's a drug like strattera that's a
treatment for ADHD well most people
don't continue taking strattera for long
periods of time because they don't
really like it very much because it's
not euphoric and doesn't work as well
you know there's a what there's a common
song a treatment called else Zamora no
one ever takes this and no one is heard
of it it's a non euphoric or MLT on the
Mel Turner chicken song it dreams no one
takes them they're not very successful
compounds relative to something like an
ambien and I think one reason is because
they're not euphoric they don't make you
feel good yeah that totally makes sense
that is a problem I'm still pissed off
about this whole benzo thing just cuz I
was so unaware of how addictive they are
like I'd taken lorazepam before
prescribed for anxiety and it just had
net like it didn't even work very well I
think the dose was too low or something
so I never like formed any sort of I
just didn't use it I used gravel
actually which worked better for calm
me down knocking me out then lorazepam
but I didn't realize like
diphenhydramine gravel yeah gravel I
used to I used to take adderall in the
morning and it was the long-lasting
types and by nighttime for some reason I
was awake like I had difficulty staying
awake all day and then at night I'd wake
up and so I take gravel to sleep rather
than lorazepam to gravels just
completely knock me out
grab ladies gravel a name for
diphenhydramine I'm not sure yeah that's
like it's gravel and can be in Canada
yeah okay I've got more questions this
is so interesting okay okay let's go
let's go back to nootropics for a second
um say you want something and this isn't
to use everyday because I also don't
believe for just from the experience
I've had with diet and everything I
don't believe that you can take
something that's going to make you
smarter continually without having some
sort of drawback when you stop taking it
I'd like I don't know if that exists
maybe if you're treating something but I
don't know even when I was ill I didn't
find something that worked and didn't
have some sort of drawback but say
you're looking for something say you're
having a bad day
and you're stressed out and you need to
get through some work so you need
something to just pep you up and help
you focus and it's just for the day what
do you do then and is caffeine night say
caffeine's off I hate Kathleen ok well I
mean you know I have a friend I know a
guy that owns this coffee company who's
doing a lot of self experiments with
various caffeine derivatives and there
are quite a few
you know there's theobromine and and
Thea Crean and there's this one I
actually hadn't heard of until recently
called methyl Librium and he said it was
amazing and I ordered some during this
pandemic to try myself and I thought it
was horrible I was really good night a
horrible to throw word I don't wanna be
unfair to end the whole liver it wasn't
it was but at 200 milligrams it was like
more unpleasant than caffeine let's say
I mean caffeine I think is a pretty
pretty nice pretty nice stimulant I'm
very grateful for it I think it's it's
like a rare instance of a drug that has
I mean for what it does it has at least
for me very very few negative effects so
I don't like it at all I did I did
23andme and ran my genes through a
couple of things and apparently I don't
know if this has anything to do with it
either but apparently I'm a fast
metabolizer of caffeine and people who
metabolize caffeine quickly it's
apparently it's the slow metabolizers
that enjoy it more but but I get an up
and then I get a crash and the crash is
like really physically uncomfortable so
I I don't like it I tried a new pepped I
really liked new pepped mmm yeah me too
I think I mean I the ones that I tried
that one seemed like the best but I
really you know I tried to be as
self-critical and skeptical when it
comes to these things as possible
because you know if you're not if you're
not really evaluating it in it and I
would even do little tests on myself but
I just don't know what to make of any of
it I mean well how would you describe
the the effect it had on you
new pepped yeah um let's see so I tried
some of the race attempts and I didn't
like most of them but new pet
um I'd get kind of like an energy
feeling in my arms just like a slight
buzzing it was almost the feeling after
you exercise a bunch that's kind of how
I felt and it doesn't seem to have like
a comedown or anything it's really minor
and I've like I've known friends who've
taken it and haven't noticed anything
but I kind of feel like I do after I
exercise or if I fast for a long time um
so I would say more focus a little bit
more irritability probably but it's
minor but I like it yeah it's been a
while since I've even looked at any
scientific literature on do pepped I was
very interested in order first came out
because at the beginning it was this
very rare material it was extremely
expensive when it first became available
on the research chemical market and
people were paying you know like several
hundred dollars a gram for it in it and
I had one pharmacologist friend who
tried it and said it was utterly amazing
and that you know had this miraculous
effect on him so from the very beginning
I thought new pepped was going to be
this this totally life-changing
substance and I I do think that colored
my initial experiences with it I don't
know what to make of any of these things
I really don't it's it's I do think that
there is a certain delusional element
with with a lot of it especially when
you look at some of these these forums
that are dedicated to nootropic
evaluation because you wonder what is it
even what does it mean that what it what
aspect of your life is being enhanced
are these people hyper functional people
I / compassionate people compared to
someone that smokes weed every day
something that I think most people watch
I guess there's a lot of people that
would even say that that you know
cannabis has a sort of eutrophic effect
but you know how functionally different
do these things truly make you do you
become you know like you don't hear
stories of people saying like oh I was
you know failing all of my classes and
then I'm now like yes sir valedictorian
as a result taking new pet
I haven't seen any kind of like sci-fi
type transformations from any of these
these compounds and maybe that's an
unfair expectation but there but there
is that hope like if a compound truly
enhanced cognition wouldn't it have all
sorts of implications wouldn't you you
know if you're a chemist couldn't you
then use the enhanced intelligence to
create a new compound that further
enhanced intelligence or and there would
be some kind of telescoping effect work
like where a Mentalist of course yeah
I was seriously looking for that but
like adderall seems like the closest
thing I think and it makes me feel like
crap yeah I like limitless because it's
a very rare instance of a movie about a
drug that has a happy ending
yeah yeah I like that
I just watched that a couple weeks ago
again yeah but it's it's you know it's a
very compelling idea and a lot of
science fiction writers have have
written stories about it and I think
that you know there's there's a reason
that the people are so fascinated by
those sorts of compounds but what I do
wonder physiologically you know what
kind of enhance how like because we have
all these different components it even
from a good neuro chemical level things
that are considered positive like the
release of neurotoxin that a lot of
people were really interested in
especially a lot of depressed people
because it had this amazing effect of
increasing hippocampal volume and
they're released G TNF and and people
thought oh that that must be good then
it just failed miserably in clinical
trials and and you know that's that's
actually become a big area of interest
in psychedelic research right now where
now that there's we're kind of on the
cusp of this psychedelic pharmaceutical
revolution the next question is okay if
we can use MDMA or psilocybin as a
pharmaceutical product can we then strip
these psychedelic properties from these
compounds and just somehow isolate
the therapeutic effect and the best
candidate for doing that is to just
concentrate on the release of these
neurotropic factors but again I don't
think that there's a really strong
reason to believe that that is
therapeutic so it's it's like yeah and
you have all kinds of you know like
whether it's yeah releasing these
neurotrophic factors by no genesis on
neurons like you know you can just go on
and on and on about what would
constitute a therapeutic effect from one
of these drugs and it just doesn't seem
clear to me that we even know what
should be done it I mean it's the same
yeah it's it's a it's a complicated
issue I mean are you of the opinion that
there are therapeutic benefits and
they're separate from the actual
psychedelic experience I don't think
anyone well there's one researchers and
publishing a lot of papers on that
subject recently and I don't think that
the evidence is really there people are
fascinated by the idea of it and that
it's not even just for the classical
psychedelics it's happening ketamine as
well people are kind of asking the same
questions is there a way to strip away
the cycle activity from these molecules
and leave only the therapeutic effects
well even if there is I think it would
be a mistake to assume that the
psychoactive effect isn't therapeutic
yeah because you know I don't think it's
a coincidence that there's something
revelatory in a psychedelic experience
and that often those revelations are
tied to the life changes that can occur
after someone uses a psychedelic in
those life changes assume that they're
positive usually come from the
experience itself right it's like you
maybe maybe it's a dietary change you
know a lot of people will look at me or
something like that while they're under
the influence of the psychedelic and
decide that they don't want to be
associated with meat because they think
it's you know cruel or disgusting in
some way that's a common thing that I've
heard people say or they and then maybe
will make them more interested in
nutrition I know that it's very much
contradict sorrow and take on this and
actually I don't know if you know this
but
one of the most famous LSD chemists in
history Ellis Lee Stanley was like a
very vocal proponent of an albeit diet
do you know about that no yeah Wow I'm
gonna Google that as soon as this is
over interesting yeah nothing to me
that's so weird okay well it's not that
weird I guess that's what I'm doing I
still think it's weird though yeah there
was another one as well
she had a his web sees dead not what his
websites still up and you can you can
see he has a whole section of it
dedicated to his exclusive consumption
of meat so funny okay
eventually what my websites gonna look
like you know those sorts of revelations
are tied to the psychoactive effect of
the drug I I find it hard to imagine
that without that psychoactive effects
you could decide that you wanted to
change your diet for example because
it's tied into looking at food in an
altered state and having a thought about
your relationship with food and there's
so many of those examples whether it's
you know yeah that totally makes sense
and all the psychedelics are using for
addiction treatment - like I would
assume that a lot of that is the actual
experience like looking at your life and
deciding this is something that you need
to change not some other benefit oh yeah
absolutely
yeah really thinking about I mean I've
even at one night yeah I've had you know
minor instances of that sort of effect
where I'll think about it you know being
like I when I was younger I would smoke
weed and and then I would kind of think
about it as like just a potential
dampening of my consciousness in some
way and we think well why would you want
to dampen it why would you ever want to
do anything whether it's alcohol or
cannabis or ambien or as an Eskimo do
you want to do anything is making you
less than what you actually are and
again that's like a direct product of
reflecting on your life in an altered
state and kind of having it but at least
at that moment was it just or
sense of like those our moments of
darkness in the timeline of my memory
and and I just don't think you could
have those sorts of revelations without
the psychoactive effect of the drug but
people are definitely exploring
exploring that in a pharmaceutical
capacity right now to see if it is
possible and I'm curious I'm all for it
if you can exert all the therapeutic
effects without a psychedelic experience
that's fantastic kind of because there's
a lot of people another irony is that
you know the people that I think could
benefit most from a psychedelic
experience are often people who are most
afraid of psychedelics
yeah or potentially can't potentially
can't tolerate it like people who are
extremely psychologically unstable yeah
I had a rough time with shrooms until I
was more stable when I was super
depressed like every trip I had was like
terrifying and then as soon as my
depression went away I was like I had
moments of bliss and obviously trips can
be they're not all like fun and games
obviously they can be have moments of
intense like unpleasantness but they
were they weren't good until I was a lot
more stable yeah yeah I mean even
something like my mother for example is
she's someone who was very afraid of all
sorts of things she could she could
never even consider watching a horror
movie you know ghosts monsters frighten
her real things frighten her all kinds
of things frightened she's she has a
very phobic existence and and I think
that one of the things that psychedelics
do most reliably are make you less
afraid sometimes almost problematically
on Africa I mean there have been because
of course there's something adaptive a
desirable but certain degree of fear but
but they make you a lot less afraid they
I remember one of the first times I used
psychedelic mushrooms being alone in a
kind of dark creepy basement and
thinking oh I'm not even slightly afraid
of being alone in the dark and this this
creepy basement in a way that normally I
would might I could kind of freak myself
out if I wanted to
thinking about like oh yeah what like
what is in that creepy part of these
actually creepy dark part but but yeah
they make you less afraid but then if
you're just overwhelmed by phobias
you're going to be so you're gonna go
into the experience so afraid that you
might not be able to benefit from it I
mean I mean I have friends like this as
well where they just right off the bat
they're so afraid of dying they're so
afraid of being arrested they're so
afraid of everything
that they can't extract benefit from the
experience that's that's a difficult
predicament yeah that is a predicament
okay I'm going to do one more question
and let you go thanks again for coming
on this has been super fun very
interesting what is the most addictive
thing you've tried is there anything
you've tried where you wouldn't do it
again just because of how addictive it
was or that's what I've done you well
yeah anything that you enjoyed like too
much in a not a good way I mean I've
tried quite a few things that just based
on their pharmacology I've known that it
would likely be the case that if I were
to continue indiscriminantly using the
compound that it could cause problems of
one kind or another and that ranges for
a number of things you know I in almost
every class certainly you know the
obvious examples would be
benzodiazepines opioids and some
dissociatives where you just know right
off the bat probably better not to see
what happens if I take this every day
for a month you know because it's gonna
cause problems so and and I've tried to
be because I've known so many people you
know big part of the work that I've done
and one of the most interesting things
about is I've met people involved in
drugs in every imaginable capacity from
you know homeless addicts to some of the
most prestigious
as pharmacologists who investigate these
areas to everything in between police
officers psychologist every sort of
person and so when you see all these
different extremes it makes you somewhat
cautious because you see all the
different types of things that happen
and and so yeah I guess I'm just in
general extremely extremely cautious
I've had close friends you know died
that close friends suffer you know
irreversible psychological problems I've
had I've seen almost every sort of thing
that you could possibly see and so it
has definitely made me extra extra
careful with these things so I would say
really with everything you know it's not
even about whether something is like so
good that I can predict that it will
cause problems down the line I would say
I approach absolutely everything with a
very high level of caution because with
something totally untested like for you
know something like little while ago is
testing an experimental
anti-inflammatory drug that had only
been used clinically in one very small
trial in humans and and so with that I
thought okay I've got to be very
conscious here because there isn't a lot
known about the potential toxicity of
this substance that's obvious but what I
think is less obvious is that people
have this false sense of security with
pharmaceutical compounds or things that
they perceived as being safe because
they've been used for such a long period
of time whether it's valium or xanax or
Prozac you know you think just because
it's FDA approved and because it's been
through clinical trials and it's been
used for however many decades that it's
safe well you know there's still
fundamental debate about the toxicity of
alcohol nicotine THC you know there's
really a lot that we don't know about
these compounds and so I would say that
regardless of what the compound is you
should approach it with a lot of caution
and what how about you dove you felt
that way yeah um I took in in university
I thought I was taking MDMA and it was
like more speed
then it should have been and I took that
once and was like I was awake all night
and I had it and I had like almost no I
was extremely uninhibited like it was
completely gone really and I had a
fantastic time and I didn't really sleep
and the next day I was it I was so
strung out it was unbelievable and I was
just like that was one of those things
where if there had been more there I
would have just kept taking it and I
think I think it was it wasn't MDMA it
was MD I want to say MD ka or something
it was some sort of weird bath salt
thing that I shouldn't have taken that
my friends and I assumed was MDMA and
clearly wasn't I'm not entirely sure BK
MDMA mescaline or something yes yeah it
was something like that I think it was
methalone and that was one of those
things where I was like I had a
fantastic time and I would never do that
again I felt horrible the next day but
that's the only thing and then obviously
benzodiazepines scare me to death now
just because of the experience my dad
has had and I've taken them like
periodically and I could tell like that
they're not good for me other than that
not really I don't think I think those
two things I was always very interesting
the idea of you know what is the most
addictive or the most euphoric or the
most this or the most that and you know
I don't know that there is I think
really depends on the person I think it
does depend on the person
mine was certainly I think it was
methalone that was like some sort of
amphetamine is definitely for me but um
so obviously I don't do that I know
myself too well but I think some I mean
some people like weed a lot and I
certainly don't so it definitely depends
on the person I think yeah okay well I
think that's all and I think the
takeaway like just be careful whatever
you ingest which is hard because most
people don't know and then you know just
even getting to the point of knowing
what you're consuming in the dose is
kind of more than most people can can
manage in this
all climate where it's and we made it
especially difficult so yeah it's tricky
it's very tricky okay where can people
find you I mean I found you on we do
Twitter and Instagram
what are your Twitter and Instagram
where should people look you up yeah my
Twitter and Instagram are Hamilton
Morris you can watch my TV show on Hulu
or streaming on Amazon or iTunes for a
couple of dollars in episode you can
also watch it on TV I think depending on
what country you're in and you can also
you know read stuff that I have online I
guess end or you know if you join my
patreon I guess you can see some more
stuff I'm also trying to do a pandemic
podcast oh you are yeah such a good idea
know people would definitely listen I
would listen yeah um okay well thanks
Hamilton thanks for coming in thanks for
inviting me
[Music]
you